been Rohrbach he covers the NBA for
Yahoo Sports his most recent article NBA
free agency primer the top players worst
values and best bargains good morning
Ben how are you great great thanks for
having me on all right do you want to
start with best bargains worst values we
know the top players where do you want
to start Oh
let's start with bargains okay bargains
yeah so I got I got Trevor Ariza Patrick
Beverley Duane wet
Dedmon Austin Rivers and Ricky Rubio now
I feel like some of these guys can go
either way where it's either you get him
for a huge bargain
well like someone like Malcolm Brogdon
where it's going to be like someone's
either going to way over pay him or they
get him for and he turns out to be a
great bargain so some of these guys can
obviously go either way but Ben how how
expensive is Malcolm Brogdon going to be
lets say the Lakers are interested in
Malcolm Brogdon what will it cost to get
a restricted free agent I mean you're
here in numbers over 20 million which
seems like I would have I mean at that
number I'd probably put him in and
overpay can't but man I don't see that
though what is Allen Crabbe making I
think he was that around 17 right I
would take Malcolm Brogdon at 20 if
Allen Crabbe is getting if Harrison
Barnes is just turning down whatever 25
million I I would love to have Malcolm
Brogdon to find the Lakers I think oh my
gosh yes he's a great defender
yeah great defender he can shoot he's a
great free-throw shooter there's no
drama he's 25 I think he's not young
young but he's you know he's mature to
go in there and I would absolutely if I
was loading up and mind the Lakers I
would go Brogdon Beverly and Bogdanovich
I would go after those three and I would
I would take on the rest of the world
yeah you think you can get those many
guys four for what is the 32 million
probably not but that was that would be
Michael Simon yeah that would be a nice
package for them what Brogdon would be
great because he can play on
ball off the balls you can guard sort of
multiple positions he's pretty pretty
big for sure point guards is there a big
name that's a bad value I mean you you
mentioned barn so I don't know like I
don't know if that's a big name or
whatever but I guess I would say someone
like to buy a terrace or Vuckovich those
guys there I mean given about how many
max slots are out there how many teams
are looking for guys you kind of expect
that those guys are going it somewhere
near that he's Kairi a good value I mean
I work out of Boston that I'm over the
Celtics for the last well there were 10
years and I would say he obviously
wasn't good value for them this year
no so I mean but he's an unbelievable
player so that's the I guess that's the
whole shift away but I mean for a four
year max contract for him as your number
one guy I would say oh no no it'd be
great yeah I don't I don't want to miss
my number one the chances of klay
Thompson leaving Golden State I would
put that a real slim yeah I saw that
yesterday you're gonna I guess maybe
meet with the Lakers and Clippers that
may just be sort of posturing to make
sure that the Warriors only up to four
max I wouldn't see anyone live in there
if you if you're looking at the Lakers
situation and you say you could place
somebody there who would you put that
that fits in that makes sense
financially but fits in with what
they're trying to do
I mean and you're not you're not talking
like Kawhi Leonard right no but I was
like I mean I guess
Kyrie sits with those guys but but bent
does this this Kawhi fit with them given
his personality and and how he played I
know he's a wonderful player but I mean
there's a reason why I don't think he's
gonna go there or a couple of reasons
right him I think he would say that's it
that's not a fit for me because like I
just look at a team to a championship
basically by myself with a bunch of like
solid players I don't want to sort of be
a secondary or third third guy with
Anthony Davis and LeBron James but for
me that's what I would say if I were him
you got him in Toronto yeah I would I
mean I would guess though that seems
like it's sort of close to 5050 with the
Clippers but I would tend to lean more
towards Toronto now this is sort of a
debt feeling but like I would think that
kawaiii would sit in there obviously
like having those three guys would be
ridiculous but you also it you know
you're looking at something like KD it
felt like you know there were teams that
were lining up for him and now you don't
get him for a year and you don't know
what you're getting after that year but
if the Knicks and nets either one they
don't get Kevin Durant it just feels
like they've been gearing up for they
cleared cap space they tanked with the
Knicks I mean everything was lining up
that they were going to get Kevin Durant
what do you think Kevin Durant owes on
that one I think I would lean towards
the mix because they can take that
gamble like that late they're so
desperate to play and somebody of that
caliber and just have him like at the
top of the bill even if he misses next
year they can't they can be bad again
next year get another top pick and then
you know shop that with those Dallas
picks and RJ Baird if they were trying
to like build a super team around Kevin
Durant for the 2020 2021 season
I just it seems like all the tea leaves
that are going towards the next there
like it is nu hurricane how it seems
like he would have just if I were him I
would have just picked up that option to
stay with the Warriors and maybe go for
20 20 free agency I was also wondering
about the Warriors with if they lose
Kevin Durant
you keep Steph you got clay rehabbing
you still have dream on you're probably
good losing boogie cousin is there a
chance that Golden State sneaks in and
does what Golden State normally does and
they get somebody that you didn't think
you know while you weren't looking that
they end up getting somebody yeah I mean
well that that the rottenness rockets
thing sore seems to open the door for
everybody where it's like oh I can just
decide I want to sign and trade for
somebody but but I just don't know if
they would have the pieces to sort of
make that work like they're their
first-round picks aren't that attractive
and they're the lower tier their rosters
and that attractive to make something
like that work and then they don't
really have the cap space to get
somebody so unless there's another sort
of situation we don't see coming like
the cousins thing last year where
somebody just took a mid-level exception
to play with them yeah well it'll be
interesting the first domino to fall do
you think will be who Ben it seems like
Kemba with the Celtics that almost
sounds like it's it's basically agreed
upon but I don't know if that's like a
domino that affects too many others I
guess it's if he doesn't go to the next
or something or the then that's still
open for Kyrie like wherever he doesn't
go is open for Kyrie but the bit next
biggest domino who knows those guys are
also flaky like Hawaii Durant Irving
that I mean I could cheat anyways I'm
taking leader inside Ben have a great
weekend I know you'll be busy we
appreciate your time thanks I appreciate
you having me on
and it's been Rohrbach
Yahoo Sports NBA writer for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]